[Musica]
l'intelligenza artificiale è in continua
evoluzione in continuo cambiamento mi fa
pensare un po' a questo bellissimo
quadro di Escher che vedete alle mie
spalle in cui ci sono tutti questi
elementi che interagiscono tra di loro
partendo da un pattern semplicissimo per
poi estendersi creando questo effetto di
metamorfosi no di continuo cambiamento
continua evoluzione partendo da un
elemento semplicissimo per poi diventare
complicato
però crea anche molta confusione no
proviamo a partire da un fatto di
attualità
poco tempo fa il garante per la
protezione dei dati personali in Italia
ha chiesto a openai l'azienda che si
cela dietro c'è GPT di fare chiarezza
circa l'utilizzo dei dati e il processo
dei dati degli utenti italiani e
l'utilizzo di chuggiti da parte dei
minori e neanche un mese openai sembra
aver risposto a tutte le questioni del
garante e da riabilitato l'accesso a
ciagpt
Questo esempio che cosa ci fa capire
secondo me essenzialmente due cose la
prima è che quello che ci stiamo dicendo
Oggi sull'intelligenza artificiale
probabilmente già non sarà più di
attualità domani e la seconda è che Crea
appunto molta confusione io dico sempre
che sembra di stare un po' nel periodo
del Far West no ci sono tanti test tante
cose nuove però allo stesso tempo tanta
paura tanta incertezza proviamo a
partire da altri esempi
la foto che vedete alle mie spalle ha
vinto il concorso internazionale Sony di
quest'anno ma c'è una particolarità la
persona che ha generato questa foto in
realtà non l'ha scattata appunto è stata
generata da un sistema di intelligenza
artificiale detto generativo e ha
rifiutato inoltre di ricevere il premio
di questo di questo concorso di
fotografia e la risposta è stata che
questo artista voleva iniziare a creare
un dibattito e chiedersi appunto Qual è
il ruolo dell'intelligenza artificiale
generative nel mondo dell'arte e
soprattutto nel mondo della fotografia
o ancora la ragazza che vedete alle mie
spalle Claudia 19 anni in realtà non
esiste è stata generata da non si sa chi
degli utenti su internet che hanno
generato dei soldi producendo e
generando delle immagini di questa
ragazza che non esiste e pubblicandone
delle foto un po' osé
o ancora che tipo di relazione abbiamo
noi con questa intelligenza artificiale
soprattutto quando possiamo dialogare
con loro prendete l'esempio della
persona anche che vedete alle mie spalle
che fa parte di uno di quegli utenti che
dialogava con un chatbot chiamato
replica tra l'altro il cui accesso è
bloccato in Italia la cui obiettivo
principale era quello di creare delle
relazioni amorose con i propri utenti
dopo un aggiornamento qualche mese fa
queste relazioni amorose non sono più
possibili questo cambiamento repentino
ha provocato uno shock emotivo
significativo da parte di questi utenti
che non solo si erano affezionati ma
alcuni di loro se ne erano addirittura
innamorati
o ancora se il caso di un professore
universitario di giurisprudenza in
un'università statunitense che si è
dovuto iniziare a difendere su un caso
di un'accusa di aggressione sessuale nei
confronti di una sua studentessa quando
in realtà questo fatto è stato
completamente inventato da chuggiti e la
notizia iniziata a girare un po' ovunque
su internet
o ancora il caso di un signore sulla
cinquantina in Belgio che si è tolto la
vita dopo aver discusso con
un'intelligenza artificiale un chatbot e
di preoccupazioni circa il cambiamento
climatico o il futuro dell'umanità
questi esempi che cosa ci fanno capire
appunto che c'è molta confusione ma
soprattutto ci fa porre delle domande
essenziali ossia Qual è il nostro ruolo
di esseri umani in questo mondo
trasformato dall'intelligenza
artificiale generativa E che tipo di
relazione dobbiamo avere con questa
intelligenza artificiale
Innanzitutto non è un monolite punti un
campo di ricerca multidisciplinare sì
che coinvolge tantissime tantissime
discipline diverse come la filosofia Le
Scienze cognitive le matematica si parla
di modelli unimodali multimodali quando
hanno ingressi e uscite di dati di
diverso tipo non è magia poiché
l'obiettivo è quello di elaborare degli
algoritmi capaci di risolvere dei
compiti complessi ma sono basati su
calcoli statistici e fisica e non
polvere di stelle e soprattutto non è
oggettiva ossia l'intelligenza
artificiale e costretta a trarre delle
generalizzazioni a partire dall'immensa
quantità di dati su cui è stata
addestrata
adesso se proviamo a fare insieme una
riflessione punto un po' sociale Quali
sono gli impatti sociali e rischi legati
all'intelligenza artificiale per l'uomo
innanzitutto se partiamo dall'individuo
Ci sono dei rischi di manipolazione e
isolamento come gli esempi che abbiamo
visto in precedenza delle persone che si
sono innamorate del loro chatbot o che
sono arrivati terzino a togliersi la
vita purtroppo soprattutto in quelle
persone che sono già fragili o
vulnerabili che sono già hanno una già
una sensibilità particolare oppure come
non menzionare l'erosione della privacy
come faceva già presente il garante come
sono trattati questi dati a chi
appartengono o ancora questi famosi
queste grandissime quantità di dati su
cui questi modelli sono allenati
appartengono a qualcuno sono stati
inizialmente prodotti da esseri umani
pensiamo ai libri storie articoli di
giornale fotografie immagini dipinti
sono la proprietà intellettuale di
esseri umani che gli hanno prodotti a
chi appartengono Come gestire il
copyright i diritti d'autore la
proprietà intellettuale in che modo
farlo
penso che queste sono questioni urgenti
che devono essere iniziate a essere di
battute già da adesso sia da un punto di
vista legale che da un punto di vista
etico
oppure se vogliamo prendere il punto di
vista della società impossibile non
menzionare appunto l'amplificazione di
fake news e la conseguente diffidenza di
tutti gli utenti di internet
tentando purtroppo di scadere in quello
che può essere definito un mondo della
post verità Che cosa vuol dire se sarà
sempre più difficile se non impossibile
distinguere un contenuto generato da
un'intelligenza artificiale ed un
contenuto di produzione puramente umano
come faremo a distinguere il vero dal
falso nel mondo di Internet è una
domanda importante da porci subito
a livello di società c'è anche una
questione fondamentale che riguarda la
concentrazione del potere ossia Chi
produce questi sistemi intelligenza
artificiale Di chi sono e a cosa servono
quali sono gli obiettivi e in che modo
influenzano questo scacchiere
geopolitico internazionale Chi sono gli
attori principali con quali obiettivi li
stanno sviluppando e ancora una volta ma
che cosa servono a cosa serve dialogare
con questi sistemi
Proviamo a vedere un po' Come funziona
nel mondo se iniziamo dagli Stati Uniti
possiamo definire il valore che è dato
all'intelligenza artificiale generativa
come intrinseco ossia l'obiettivo
principale è quello di riprodurre
un’intelligenza umana o addirittura
superiore ad un intelligenza umana
richiamando quella che forse avrei
sentito parlare un intelligenza
artificiale e generale ossia capace di
apprendere come un bambino e di rendersi
conto dello spazio che lo circonda
l'approccio appunto per prevenire i
rischi e gli impatti che abbiamo
precedentemente menzionato possono
essere definiti come preventivi ossia si
cerca di definirle i limiti e le
vulnerabilità un esempio classico che
esiste nel team di ingegneri Soprattutto
molto famoso negli Stati Uniti è il
concetto di rate timing ossia squadre
rosse sono degli ingegneri che lavorano
a cercare le vulnerabilità di un sistema
di intelligenza artificiale generativo
in particolare al fine appunto di
poterlo divulgare in modo più sicuro
Se invece ci spostiamo in Europa
potremmo definire il valore
dell'intelligenza artificiale come
strumentale ossia ci si concentra di più
su quali sono i casi di applicazione
concreti e torniamo alla nostra famosa
domanda Ma cosa dobbiamo farci quindi ci
si concentra molto di più sui casi di
applicazione Pensiamo ad esempio alle
discussioni che sono attualmente in
corso sulle iacted nelle nostre
istituzioni europee dove si definiscono
dei campi precisi di applicazione
l'approccio molto simile a quello
statunitense può essere definito
normativo ossia si cerca di sviluppare
una regolamentazione a livello europeo
Dunque internazionale e nazionale sullo
sviluppo di nuove leggi regole e il modo
in cui deve far parte del nostro
Quotidiano
se ci spostiamo poi in Asia Cina grande
attore dello sviluppo dell'intelligenza
artificiale Oggi possiamo definire il
valore che è affidato appunto attribuito
all'intelligenza artificiale come
conservativo qualche settimana fa il
governo cinese ha pubblicato un
documento in cui spiegava che il primo
obiettivo dell'intelligenza artificiale
generativa e quello di promuovere il
valore del socialismo per quello l'ho
definito
conservativo poiché l'obiettivo
principale è quello di conservare un po'
lo status quo che esiste già nella loro
società
una cosa però da notare interessante è
che l'approccio di
prevenzione tra virgolette non è così di
prevenzione poiché lo possiamo definire
esemplare Nel senso che cercano di
all'opposto dell'approccio più
occidentale di dare il buon esempio di
guidare attraverso degli esempi dati
dagli sviluppatori dati dalle aziende
date dal governo o da qualsiasi altra
entità per mostrare il buon utilizzo e
buoni casi di applicazione Dunque vedete
come ci troviamo un po' all'opposto del
Risk prevention della prevenzione di
rischi in cui si cerca di essere più
proattivi
ma in tutto ciò se a prescindere dagli
obiettivi un po' dei maggiori attori
sullo scacchiere internazionale proviamo
a fare un'analisi etica insieme
dell'intelligenza artificiale
ci siamo detti che soprattutto in quelli
più comuni immagino avrete visto Forse
provato cioè gbt stiamo interagendo con
le macchine dunque non si tratta di una
tecnologia qualunque una tecnologia con
cui siamo in grado di dialogarci in
linguaggio naturale opposto al
linguaggio artificiale e un linguaggio
appunto puramente umano Ma se possiamo
interagire con queste macchine Qual è il
tipo di relazione che dobbiamo avere e
soprattutto cosa c'è in gioco
Beh Secondo me se vogliamo partire da
una riflessione etica importante porre
l'accento su la responsabilità morale
dell'interazione di Questa interazione
tra di noi e ci sono dei fattori da
considerare in Questa interazione e
soprattutto per rispondere alla domanda
Come fare un buon utilizzo
dell'intelligenza artificiale di fattori
come dicevo da considerare sono diversi
come dei rischi psicocognitivi e
l'imprevedibilità umana possiamo
menzionare l'antopromorfizzazione ossia
la capacità umana di attribuire delle
capacità cognitive o puramente umane a
degli strumenti che in realtà sono
interamente artificiali come la
proiezione di valori sentimenti
innamorarci o esserci completamente
antipatici
oppure ci sono
quando parlo di imprevedibilità umana
parlo probabilmente l'avete visto anche
voi di questa voglia un po' di testare i
limiti un po' da soli mentre dialoghiamo
con questi agenti conversazionali avrete
forse sentito parlare dei famosi
jailbreaks di George PT ossia utenti di
internet che si divertono a farli dire
delle cose che possono diventare persino
pericolose e dicevamo siccome un sistema
di intelligenza artificiale rimane
statistico come può predire
l'imprevedibilità umana domanda aperta e
soprattutto anche alla insomma in vista
degli esempi che abbiamo menzionato
all'inizio come possiamo gestire la
fragilità dei più vulnerabili tra di noi
noi esseri umani
penso che la risposta una delle risposte
Innanzitutto può essere di rimettere al
centro della discussione del dibattito
l'umanità quello che ci rende umani e
rimetterci al centro Che cosa significa
Innanzitutto dobbiamo porci laggressione
di Qual è il valore strumentale di
questa intelligenza artificiale che sono
capaci di dialogare insieme a noi penso
che esistono tanti tanti esempi e tanti
punti fondamentali Ma innanzitutto sono
devono essere le macchine ad adattarsi
agli esseri umani e non viceversa devono
essere le macchine a dover imparare da
noi dai nostri difetti dei nostri rischi
dalle nostre emozioni e non viceversa
Inoltre è importante definire delimitare
dei campi di applicazione precisi di
queste Eia conversazionali e delimitarle
e soprattutto interessante guidare lo
sviluppo e l'utilizzo di intelligenza
artificiale attraverso degli esempi
il buon esempio soprattutto
Dunque per concludere la generativa
penso che rappresenti un'opportunità
unica per il nostro genere sia a livello
individuale e sia a livello di società
Esistono degli esempi concreti visto che
ci siamo detti soltanto degli esempi
negativi e importante ricordare anche in
quei casi in cui funziona piuttosto bene
forse conoscerete al fafold sviluppato
Da deepmind quale un sistema di
intelligenza artificiale perché riesce a
prevedere la struttura di
tridimensionale di una proteina basato
semplicemente dalla lettura del codice
genetico o ancora dei modelli di
linguaggio utilizzati per riconoscere
dei pattern linguistici in quei soggetti
affetti di schizofrenia depressione o
spettro dell'autismo e dunque aiutare
nella diagnosi psichiatrica ma se vi
parlo di questi esempi sono da
bilanciare perché appunto sono
delimitati in campo specifico sono
accompagnati da dei professionisti e
sono delimitati appunto in uno strumento
unico
dunque se rimettiamo l'umanità Al centro
c'è questa bellissima copertina del New
York che richiama appunto Il nostro caro
Asher che in fondo ci fa riflettere su
una cosa importante ossia noi esseri
umani interagendo con queste macchine in
fin dei conti le queste stesse macchine
finiscono per parlare di noi e dunque la
nostra relazione con loro ci definisce
in quanto esseri umani Non si è mai
parlato così tanto di quanto ci rende E
cosa ci rende unicamente umani
e dunque concludendo su questo
bellissimo quadro originale di Escher
vediamo questo spessore di cerchio
virtuoso in cui è l'uomo che disegna
l'uomo e nello stesso modo se riusciamo
ad avere questa operazione ed utilizzare
l'intelligenza artificiale come
strumento al nostro servizio potranno
essere ci potrà essere un futuro
interessante per tutti gli esseri umani
ora la domanda è siamo pronti a
svilupparla e ad utilizzarla in modo
etico
Grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]